dreamers of space have always had their
eyes there their hopes their aspirations
on getting to Mars are as has to look
that the sky saw that that thought and
wondered what's on it as soon as people
understood what planets were some of
them said wouldn't it be neat to go
there
the modern fascination with Mars began
with Percival Lowell he was wealthy
enough to build his own Observatory and
he was convinced that Mars had life and
he writes about this the seed was
planted in the hearts and minds of the
public that maybe the planets have life
shortly after he published his books the
novel War of the Worlds comes out where
did those aliens come from Mars for
whatever reason we have been talking
about the Red Planet and little green
men the red planet Mars
for over 2,000 years the symbol for war
it's been part of movies and shows and I
think it's just because it's this next
next planet and it looks really cool new
adventures in undreamed-of places
all of this led to an early 20th century
sense that there's probably something
there you'll be the next to attack sign
and maybe yeah right into oblivion the
public perception of going to Mars and
going to the moon is what pushed us to
go there